[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild der Fall im letzten November
verschwand der Geschäftsführer des
buchuma wurstherstellers Zimbo spurlos
und mit ihm seine Frau die Polizei habte
zunächst völlig im Dunkeln vermutete ein
Wirtschaftsverbrechen DDR lokalsendung
aus dem Jahr
1997 da ging es schon um den
Strafprozess am Anfang dieser Geschichte
standen aber ratlose Polizisten und ein
doppelter vermissten Fall die Wahrheit
dahinter machte alle umso fassungsloser
und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Tony Haier und mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir hallo und herzlich Willkommen
auch von mir wie ihr gleich hören werdet
unterstützt uns auch dieses Mal wieder
bildre
Schneider im November 1996 machen sich
Freunde und Angehörige Sorgen um den
43-Jährigen Peter Schulte Berthold und
seine 6 Jahre jüngere Frau Christine die
beiden kommen aus Witten in
Nordrheinwestfalen Berthold ist Manager
beim bekannten fleischhersteller Zimbo
am 7 November stehen in vielen Zeitungen
Meldungen wie diese aus dem Hamburger
abendplatt das ehepaus Witten das mit
Wurst und Fleischwaren zu Millionären
wurde ist seit Tagen verschwunden
einzige Spur der Polizei Blut vor der
Garage wurde der Geschäftsführer
gekidnappt eine
Familientragödie fest steht gestern
sollte Berthold für die Lüdenscheider
fleischfirma Zimbo nach Ungarn fliegen
doch auf dem Flughafen kam er nie an
sein Firmenwagen ein Mercedes der
E-Klasse ist ebenfalls verschwunden
Schulte Berthold war die rechte Hand von
zimboch Chef Reinhold Zimmermann er
arbeitete seit den 60er Jahren für ihn
Zimbo Senior Zimmermann er hat sich
weder krank noch abgemeldet es muss
etwas Furchtbares passiert
sein Blut vor der Garage
bildchefreporter Frank Schneider damals
noch junger nachwuchsredakteur im
lokalen sieht die Szenarie noch
detaillierter vor sich also ich kann
mich persönlich noch sehr sehr gut dran
erinnern wie die Polizei dort
Spurensicherung betrieben hat in der
Garagen Auffahrt und eben auch in der
Garage dort sah man eben auch von der
Straße aus dass dort eben ein Blutfleck
war es herrschte große Verwirrung es war
ein sehr zuverlässiger seriöser
Geschäftsmann und er war nur mit seiner
Ehefrau verschwunden erst dachte man
möglicherweise an in der Entführung
dachte dann er hätte vielleicht auch
gelderf un selber weg geflogen abgehauen
es gab dann auch noch das Gerücht es g
einen Flugticket aber Mate erst so keine
richtig Spur konnte sich überhaupt nicht
erklären was da passiert ist und dann
hat man nach dem Fahrzeug gefahrenet
einen damaligen E-Klasse Mercedes und
den hat man schließlich in Dortmund
gefunden und im Kofferraum lagen dann
eben der Mann und auch die Frau beide
wirklich bestialisch umgebracht muss man
sagen mit Butterflymesser und
Skalpell und weil es um sehr reiche
Leute geht und um eine große Firma
vermuten Ermittler und Öffentlichkeit
auch eine große Geschichte gab es etwa
internationale Verwicklungen illegale
Millionengeschäfte vielleicht sogar
Verbindungen in die Unterwelt aber es
dauert nur wenige Tage bis die Wahrheit
ans Licht kommt und die ist umso banaler
und erschreckender Frank Schneider dann
kam relativ schnell raus dass dort
obwohl um geldstreitigkeit ging davon
hatten sie nämlich schon bekannten und
Familienmitgliedern erzählt dass sie
einem Arbeitslosen Verkäufer aus
Dortmund Geld gegeben hatten der Ihnen
eine Stereo und highi Anlage und auch
TV-Anlage installieren sollte mit
externen Boxen und ich meine wir reden
hier von 1996 da war das noch was ganz
besonderes es ging um sehr viel Geld
eine mittlere fünfstellige Summe und
dieses Geld hatte er verspielt und nur
hatte er Angst das zuzu Z geben später
vor Gericht sagte der 26jährige Mörder
er hätte insbesondere Angst vor seiner
Mutter gehabt zuzugeben dass er das
gemacht hat und der Geschäftsführer von
Zimbo hat halt irgendwann Druck auf ihn
ausgeübt woher sich die beiden kannten
das hat damals am 30 November 1996 die
Bild
berichtet gemeinsamer Schnittpunkt der
Millionär war ein HFI Fan Oliver F jobte
in einem Dortmunder stereio Geschäft der
Millionär war dort Stammkunde die Firma
ging vor 4er Jahren pleite die zwei
Männer blieben in Kontakt jetzt sollte
Oliver im Wohnzimmer des wurstmanagers
eine 50.000 Mark teure Audio
Stereoanlage installieren so unter der
Hand bekam für den Ankauf von Geräten
schon mal 20 000 Mark und verjubelte das
Geld gab ihm als teilweise Rückzahlung
einen Scheck über 5000 Mark an der aber
war
ungedeckt okay Mirko jetzt nicht sauer
sein aber ich glaub du als der ältere
von uns beiden mhm du musst mir da mal
bitte kurz was erklären also wie kann
man denn bitte
50.000 Mark ausgeben für eine
Stereoanlage so 5000 oder 10.000 ja
vielleicht aber so viel also liebe Tony
vielen Dank für das
Kompliment also liebe Tony ich sag mal
so also ich als Sprecher und Musiker hab
natürlich auch eine Menge Technik bei
mir im Studio stehen und ich sag mal so
man kann dafür schon ohne weiteres sehr
sehr viel Geld ausgeben mühelos und so
hochpreisige hier Anlagen ja das war
schon immer so ein Special interesting
und sicher nur ein ganz bestimmten
Klientel vorbehalten nämlich der die
sich das wirklich leisten kann und die
dann solche Technik auch irgendwie ja
als Prestige ansieht na ja okay also ich
würde von dem Geld jetzt z. lieber eine
Weltreise machen oder andere Dinge
kaufen aber okay das darf ja jeder mit
seinem Geld machen wie er möchte
zurück zum Fall wir wissen jetzt wie der
wurstmillionär seinen Mörder
kennengelernt hat aber wie kam die
Polizei ihm auf die Spur er ist
aufgeflogen weil es Spuren gab in seine
Richtung weil es eben um dieses Geld
ging davon hatten sie
Familienmitgliedern schon erzählt und
dann hat er später als die Polizei
befragt hat sich relativ schnell in
Widersprüche verwickelt und relativ
schnell die Taten auch gestanden und ist
dann relativ schnell nachdem die beiden
im Auto gefunden wurden auch in
Untersuchungshaft gegangen und dann
später eben auch verurteilt worden Bild
ordnet unseren Täter damals so ein
Oliver F 26 aus Dortmund Arbeitsloser
Kaufmann einziger Sohn ehrbarer Eltern
sein Vater war
gefängnisbeamter wahrscheinlich war die
Mutter ehrbare Hausfrau aber das steht
jetzt nicht auf jeden Fall hatte Oliver
F in einem Elektronik und hi Geschäft
gearbeitet und immer mal wieder Aufträge
für Schulte Berthold erledigt Geräte
installiert Kabel verlegt sowas halt und
zwar auch als das Geschäft pleite ging
und Oliver F arbeitslos wurde später
also soll F für die Villa in Witten eine
neue TV und Musikanlage besorgen und
bekommt dafür Geld um schon mal die
Anzahlungen für diese Geräte zu leisten
genauer gesagt die 20 000 Mark die uns
eben schon in dem alten bildartikel
begegnet sind nur f verjubelt das Geld
macht sich davon ein schönes Leben
begleicht Schulden
es Wochen vergehen und immer wieder
fragt Schulte Berthold nach
wahrscheinlich in etwa so Mensch Olli
was ist denn jetzt mit der Anlage ich
habe dich schon so oft gefragt jetzt wo
bleibt die denn ja Chef das dauert
leider alles ein bisschen das sind ja
auch teure importkomponenten aus Japan
dabei ja ich weiß ja aber trotzdem ist
das schon ewig her jetzt ist mit den
Anzahlungen alles klar gegangen geht
alles sein Gang Herr Schulte Berthold
ihr Geld ist gut
angelegt irgendwann aber verliert der
Millionär die Geduld und Pleitegeier
Oliver F muss improvisieren erstmal gibt
der Schulte Berthold einen Scheck über
5000 Mark um seinen guten Willen zu
zeigen um einen Teil der Anzahlung
zurückzugeben aber der Check ist nicht
gedeckt als sein Auftraggeber damit
droht etwas gegen ihn zu unternehmen da
fasst Oliver einen teuflischen Plan
Frank Schneider er ist dann zu ihm nach
Hause gekommen und hat gesagt ja ich
habe die Sachen jetzt besorgt aber das
ist so schwer das Material das kann ich
nicht alleine tragen da müssen sie mir
helfen und dann sind die beiden mit
einem Mercedes losgefahren und sind nach
Schwerte auf ein einsames Gelände auf
einem Parkplatz und dort sollten
angeblich die Sachen in einem
Lieferwagen sein dort war natürlich
nichts und im Auto hat er dem dann schon
mit einem skypell in Hals gestochen dann
versucht er noch aus dem Fahrzeug zu
fliehen ist er im hinterher hat ih
schließlich mit Butterflymesser mehr als
ein Dutzend Mal in den Rücken gestochen
hat er die gleichen Kofferraum gepackt
ist mit dem Fahrzeug eiskalt nach Witten
zurückgefahren in die
Garage wie ist aus dem harmlosen hi
Techniker mit dem Babyface plötzlich ein
skrupelloser Killer geworden später im
Prozess versucht der Richter diesen
schrecklichen Tag im Herbst 1996 zu
begreifen der Richter was geschah
unterwegs im Auto Oliver ich fuhr mit
Herrn Schulte Berthold durch die Gegend
schließlich hien wir von dem
friedhofsparkplatz
Richter und dann Oliver er drohte alles
meiner Mutter zu erzählen da zog ich das
skypel aus der Tasche und stach zu wir
stürzten beide aus dem Auto kämpften wir
waren voller Blut ich habe ihn dann in
den Kofferraum gelegt
Richter was führten sie danach Oliver
nichts ich saß noch 5 Minuten im
Auto Richter und die
Frau die Frau Christa Schulte Berthold
37 Jahre alt das ist das nächste
schreckliche Kapitel in diesem Fall
Oliver F hat jetzt den Toten Millionär
im Kofferraum und fährt mit dessen Auto
eineem Mercedes 260E zur Villa in Witten
völlig cool und ungerührt entschlossen
den nächsten Schritt zu gehen ist dann
zur Frau und hat gesagt sie müssen mir
helfen die Sachen sind so schwer und ihr
Mann der hat sich auch verletzt der kann
das nicht machen sie müssen mir helfen
kommen S mit in die Garage dann ist die
Frau mit in die Garage und ist dort dann
auch sofort attackiert worden von ihm
mit 19 Messerstichen getötet worden die
hatte dann wium auch in den Kofferraum
gelegt und ist dann mit dem Fahrzeug
nach Dortmund gefahren und hat den auch
noch daran sieht man wie wie ungeplant
es doch am Ende war abgestellt in der
Nähe seines Wohnortes was natürlich
später auch gegen ihn sprach chr Schulte
Berthold hat gerade mit ihrer Schwester
telefoniert als Oliver trifft er selbst
schildert es im Prozess so ich fuhr zur
Villa klingelte sie öffnete fragte wo
das Blut herkomme ich sag ach nicht
schlimm bin gestürzt ich habe sie in den
Keller gelockt gab er einen Schlag gegen
den Hals sie fiel sofort um da habe ich
ihren Kopf in beide Hände genommen und
viermal auf dem Boden geknallt dann
holte ich aus der Küche ein Brotmesser
und Star zu sie
verblutete spätestens jetzt mit müssen
wir mal kurz feststellen dass Oliver F
als Mörder nicht so clever war er hat
nacheinander beide Ehepartner ermordet
jede Menge Spuren hinterlassen z.B vor
allem Blut im Auto und in der Villa und
er muss jetzt entscheiden wie es
weitergeht F fährt mit dem Mercedes nach
Dortmund stellt den Wagen wenige hundert
Meter von der Wohnung seiner Eltern ab
bei denen er wohnt später fährt er mit
dem Bus in die todesvilla zurück weil er
jetzt versuchen will die Blutspuren zu
verwischen
Bild schreibt damals sehr
detailliert als er sich im Bad das Blut
seiner Opfer von den Händen wusch wird
der Boden nass er weiß dass seine
Fußabdrücke ihn verraten könnten da
zieht er seine Schuhe aus und geht in
den Badelatschen des ermordeten
Millionärs rückwärts aus der
Tür aber selbst wenn er alle Spuren im
Haus in den Griff bekommen hätte es
bleibt ja noch das Auto der damalige
Leiter der Mordkommission sagte eben es
war alles voll Blut und dort lag auch
die Tatwaffe mit dem Kofferraum das
Messer außerdem auch die Personalpapiere
und er hat das mehr oder weniger einfach
alles in den Kofferraum geschmissen den
Kofferraumdeckel zugemacht den Wagen
weggefahren als wäre es dann so mehr
oder weniger nicht passiert aber Oliver
F scheint sich seiner Sache sehr sicher
zu sein tatsächlich fährt er als das
Ehepaar schon gesucht wird zur Polizei
er meldet sich als Zeuge er habe die
Eheleute als letztes lebend gesehen als
er im Haus schon mal die Installations
Arbeiten für die neue Stereoanlage
vorbereitet
habe einen Tag später steht die Polizei
vor der Tür der Familie F um Oliver zu
verhaften ein Neffe des ermordeten
Paares wusste von dem Streit ums Geld
und hatte sich bei den Ermittlern
gemeldet der Fall ist schnell gelöst
nach wenigen Tagen ist der Schuldiger
ermittelt und im darauffolgenden Jahr
läuft der Prozess vor seiner Mutter
wollte er nicht als Betrüger erscheinen
und deshalb steht seit heute ein 26
Jahre alter Mann wegen Doppelmordes vor
dem Landgericht in Bochum der Fall im
letzten November verschwand der
Geschäftsführer des Bochumer
wurstherstellers Zimbo spurlos und mit
ihm seine Frau die Polizei tappte
zunächst völlig im Dunkeln vermutete ein
Wirtschaftsverbrechen als dann Tage
später die Leichen der Eheleute gefunden
wurden wollte man das Motiv für den
Doppelmord kaum glauben Opfer und Täter
hatten sich wegen eines Fernsehers und
einer Stereoanlage gestritten und der
Täter der das Geld für die Geräte
unterschlagen hatte fürch sich vor dem
Ärger mit seiner Mutter Oliver F wird
schließlich wenig überraschend wegen
vorsätzlichen zweifachen Mordes zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt und was ich
ganz spannend finde an diesem Fall
oliver hat überhaupt gar keines Grupe
alle zu belügen und zu betrügen und
sogar Morde zu begehen also ich meine er
hätte auch einfach sagen können ich habe
das Geld ausgegeben ich habe mich nicht
darum gekümmert und ich kann es dir auch
nicht zurückzahlen aber er geht soeit
dass ein Ehepaar ermordet nur um zu
verhindern dass seine Mutter von seinem
ganzen Lebensstil von seinen Schulden
und von all seinen Fehlern irgendetwas
mitbekommt sehr gut gesagt Tony und
damit sind wir am Ende unseres heutigen
falls angelangt wir freuen uns dass ihr
mit dabei wart und wie immer freuen wir
uns auch natürlich wenn ihr uns Kritik
schreibt wenn ihr uns fallvorschläge
schickt wenn ihr uns einfach Nachrichten
schickt und uns schreibt wie toll er uns
findet wie das geht das findet wie immer
in den Show das Skript zum heutigen Fall
das Stamm von Stefan nitzeband und viele
Einzelheiten von Frank Schneider
Aufnahme und schnitt Tony haer
Postproduktion schwarz audio berlin und
falls ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt
dann abonniert diesen Podcast ganz egal
wo ihr hört also z.B auf Apple Spotify
Amazon dieser oder oder oder und lasst
uns natürlich auch gerne noch eine
Bewertung da danke schön bis zum
nächsten mal eure Toni und mir ciao
ciao die hat diese Folge von Tat
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende fäler
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei T Deutschland